while the unrest in Venezuela has been
occupying minds in Washington for weeks
the anti-government protests in Haiti
which saw six people killed have been
largely ignored on Wednesday hundreds
marched to the National Palace in the
country's capital calling for the
president to step down demonstration
quickly descended into chaos
angry over rising prices economic
stagnation and corruption protesters
hurled rocks at police while riot
officers tried to disperse the crowd
with tear gas and we spoke about the
demonstrations both in Haiti and just
across the Caribbean in Venezuela with
William Robinson the professor of Latin
American Studies ad is facing a
crippling socio-political and economic
crisis it's getting worse inflation is
meaning that food increasingly out of
the reach of poor people unemployment is
high and it's is rising the Haitian
government is a close ally of the United
States it's as simple as that United
States is pointing to destabilize and
overthrow the Venezuelan government for
for the last 20 years and at the same
time it has been propping up an elite
far-right wing government incredibly
corrupt government which rules over a
social order which benefits a tiny
minority for the last 30 40 50 years so
that's nothing new I mean it's not done
not any surprise but it does demonstrate
the complete hypocrisy and double
standard of u.s. foreign policy
towards the region and towards these two
countries ad has gone through nearly
three decades now of constant foreign
us-led intervention the u.s. is already
intervening behind the scenes that has
never stopped intervening Haiti is one
of the most intervened country may be
the most intervened in the whole Western
Western Hemisphere
you